nuevamente piden la destitución de yahir
bolsonaro miles de personas salieron a
las calles en más de 400 ciudades de
brasil para protestar por la gestión de
la pandemia por los cargos por
corrupción en la compra de vacunas y por
la posición del mandatario a favor de la
explotación de áreas protegidas en la
amazonía piden también acelerar el
proceso de vacunación
estoy aquí para que la gente sepa que
vivimos en un gobierno negacionista las
vacunas debían llegar hace mucho tiempo
muchas familias han perdido amigos y
familiares parecen ser amiwis miembros
de partidos opositores sociedad civil
sindicatos fueron parte de esta jornada
y hoy somos 507 ciudades unidas contra
bolsonaro y sólo dejaremos las calles
cuando el deje la oficina que usurpó
en el transcurso de la jornada los
enfrentamientos estallaron entre
manifestantes y policías en sao paulo la
ciudad más poblada del país y la más
golpeada por la pandemia lo mismo
ocurrió en río de janeiro y brasilia la
policía lanzó gases lacrimógenos tras
ser atacada por un grupo de encapuchados
que destruyeron fachadas de entidades
bancarias esto agudizó la atención los
enfrentamientos siguieron hasta horas de
la noche las protestas se dan en un
momento crítico de la carrera de
bolsonaro investigaciones en la fiscalía
por irregularidades en la respuesta del
gobierno a la pandemia y más de 540 mil
muertes a causa del copy 19 contribuyen
a que el mandatario enfrente su peor
momento desde su llegada al poder